hey guys we've gathered every cinematic
cutscenes shown from Wolfenstein to the
new Colossus thus far
so please enjoy and remember to
subscribe for more gameplay
the old and the weak are doomed
Oh
oh it's very wet means the system is
works down stops in treasure Cove ever
there's very nice contraption
quick-quick
now mr. Baskin can very happy to see you
awake not so are you out of where is she
I found my soul she was said she was
with Caroline defending the self lesson
elevator then point me in that direction
[ __ ] you know how long you've been in
bed five months your body is broken you
understand kidneys are failing
you you might have difficulties due to
urinate use your schmeckle to do men no
time for this
probably angle
she's moving heaven and earth education
around you not reach the u-bahn many
wonders many said I was separated from
the others I have to go no no - ism
china get social said help me find the
sale platform elevator you are such an
auction go on touch a notch it okay now
there are many Nazis between here and
the cell platform elevator bot I said
several traps I didn't have the time to
activate them but look at this and that
to show you where the traps are
beautiful try not to get killed if you
don't mind okay William I prayed for you
to wake up
number
don't be stupid okay let's get you up
[Music]
you gotten so fat that says we're having
twins
not now Jindal Asifa survivors have
enough time Fishman said I let's get you
outside onto the deck
you
now so I'm Buddha yoga kind of Papa no
despite
yes I'm Samoa
Ishmael Testament revenge for
indigestion long time another cool
I know about media
many clinics are specific
No
-
they set it up
let us talk it out megaphone
[Applause]
have our people she trapped our best
lunch what can we do right but have to
somehow release our you were clumsy
awful I can't lose you
you're weak William you're in no shape
to fight
you're going to run us over if you know
wheelchair
good what a funny sight the mastermind
crawling around at all oh you're weak
what love to me I came for you are you
all now Caroline know how she flows
I [ __ ] up somehow she tracked us down
I [ __ ] everything up
you think your hero William Joseph does
coach
it also covers
[Music]
only the everyone will see what it
useless
joke you are
Oh
did that cop
[Music]
though your head don't be suing the
resistance does not bow
[Music]
pickles sliced and is a vitamin a start
to do services have a storage though the
Zion cup for instance on the defensive
and mystical animal important who cannot
achieve the Luminara bomb box that's us
please when a son cancer
you don't I try to focus you must give
into the fight
[Music]
[Music]
I'll set
helicopters good to go thanks man I
think it's time we had a gathering enter
and pass it through the gates to attain
to the thirty-two pads of the wisdom
back but in reference to life a little
storm man you ticklish buddy back Jesus
max I can see their welcome back time
doing some like really heavy reading
here and your little toy robot is just
not compatible with that type of
soldiering man okay that's odd max it's
alright pal look that's just way too
complicated for you why don't you go
play with your pig or something see I'm
trying to find the reference to these
gates here and there she just would not
understand max max this is really
advanced philosophical literature here
okay you can't just start pointing this
max that's it how did you beat you in
the helm why
all right y'all we got some hell to
raise you got a boat full of news and I
got a target [ __ ] good one - oh yeah
that's where it's at that's cool all
right okay check it out
I send specially ahead to this home town
of Roswell New Mexico to prep for the
mission now there's a tunnel that's
accessible through specially hideout
that will take you straight into the
Nazis top secret underground base where
they're experimenting with some sort of
wigged out
alien technology which will look secure
this is really loose but you mean fun of
yours yeah wouldn't you like to know so
you can send coded messages back to your
pals in Berlin no what the [ __ ] is she
even doing here grace why she's good
people she's a [ __ ] Nazi on your boat
were you saying past a secret base you
were talking about was constructed by us
that's you one of our biggest safe keeps
it was located here underground what is
now Roswell New Mexico but it existed
for a thousand years long before America
got subjugated by the Europeans
it contained technology related to
anti-gravity research something that
could easily turn the tide of war
we gave the US government access to it
unfortunately was too late America fell
the Nazis took hold my safety
[ __ ] that's not going to sit well with
specially he had his bed on space aliens
he wants to ship the crash back there in
47 what do you want with this place know
what the Oberkommando is yeah baby
that's roll those bigshot jerks running
the Nazi war machine hangout yeah well
the Nazis moved it into your safety set
so whatever it is is so important that
the whole upper echelon of the Nazi
leadership left Berlin instead of shot
in New Mexico this is why you need this
ha ha this is a portable nuclear bomb
we're going to take out the Oberkommando
[ __ ] the Nazi leadership and
destabilize the [ __ ] country and let
the people know that the fight is back
on blaskowitz load up I'm sending you to
Roswell with Roswell as out of
helicopter range so we'll drop you off
by the coast in Galveston from there you
will catch a ride to Roswell rendezvous
was super special at Papa Joe's
all-american diners and plant the new
inside the very heart of the over
commander then he blow that [ __ ] the
[ __ ]
[Music]
just house to host gallant Peter
mr. German gear needed fall and you walk
in that there few her is an grosser
outer and melon that groups my younger
Bobby told me that the few her painted
the Mona Lisa then he made the atom bomb
then he put my head in the toilet and
flushed it that's awful
someone should teach him Bobby some
manners you can bet you're behind his
mother won't do it I want you to promise
me you'll stay away from him
are you listening to me Peter now
something from the menu which the secret
police hadn't taken away to help when
will we ever get home-cooked meals again
mom can I get chili sure can yes we ever
get service in this Oscar old place
oh hello there sir please have a seat at
the counter
I'll be right with you ma'am will it be
here was closed right
it's to go we'll be quick Ricky I'll
have the last word
special knows you come in to attack the
Oberkommando but he has no idea if you
bring in a damn atom bomb you got a
break in the news hello
come on Peter let's go someplace else
mom know anyone oh we should yeah
good day ma'am you one strawberry
milkshake please oh I hope you don't
have a fire back there to put out if so
I'll come back another time
I'm sure the fire can wait come and done
covering up a man you recognize your
face very Aryan face that is - so you
want a station one there you come that
all fear and dank hmm now you show me
your identification papers please
I love strawberry milkshake perhaps my
favorite American food so simple just
milk and ice cream the rest of the menu
however I think you will need to address
I think it needs to be more German yeah
tell me are you from here John Smith huh
I read here that you operate out of
station six what is the location of
station six I'm familiar with this
station
speak up come on
we had some Pokemon to pelant well as
the tide clink upon my death wish not
[Music]
[Music]
anonymous
Oh Leslie shut the [ __ ] front door or
anymore God give nothing now that I'll
trust you blaskowitz there's nothing
saying you couldn't be wearing a mask
made to look like William Jay blast
course to hide your alien space lizard
facial traced it so I mean the password
grace gave you she didn't give me one
right off with a mask
show me your lizard face mother [ __ ]
Super Stretch lower your weapon front
break your arm and put your lights out
thank you with you ter Billy good I just
[ __ ] with you come follow me so
welcome to Mission Control much what you
have to clean up around here I'm sorry
about that it's um good stuff this [ __ ]
right here
it keeps the signal from getting through
very effective against alien mind
reading devices how's grace
good a big em finest cream gravy Christ
I miss her
even the pissing in the face part and
maybe I miss that the most
okay little [ __ ] so what even doing
down here super special displays my
pontiff need used this place to collect
all the evidence we could find with the
government cover-up cookie ah it didn't
been more than a decade now summer 47 I
was just saying here I quit working as a
lawyer in the year I joined the black
revolutionary front after I got great
the quiz from that murder charge the
goddamn FBI pigs trumped-up against her
then one night Papa heard something on
police frequency and he brought me up
north to Murphy's ranch we found this
flying saucer life thing had crashed in
the ground
and when you know it the u.s.
[ __ ] military swooped in and
quarantined off the entire Peru it was
some kind of [ __ ] story about a
whoop balloon they were lying out of
their asses because we made off some
actual hard evidence here take a look at
this huh pulled that baby right out of
the crash site now does that look like
something that came off a wet alone this
place as we kept the records I started
surveilling with the military is up to
Papa built most of them so you reckon
what you saw was a spaceship I'm not
saying it a flying saucer from outer
space but he was clearly
extraterrestrial in origin if you catch
my drift
it's all [ __ ] connected men if you
trace the chain of causation you find
yourself in a secret underground
facility about 10 klicks east of Roswell
up by bottomless lakes area 52 our
government captured an alien flying
saucer and they stored the salvaged
bodies and Technology in an underground
vault everyone was involved the FBI pigs
the military pigs even the goddamn King
Presidente himself
check this [ __ ] out area 52 area 51 over
here area 248 area 56 all over the
southwest Nevada New Mexico it's one
gigantic
complex and it's connected by
underground train tunnels I look like a
fixtures plasma guns mind control
anti-gravity engines and after our
coward-ass governments surrender to the
[ __ ] Nazi pigs our new masters took
over all these bases and they kept doing
their own experiments due to further
their own fascist agenda look at this
this whole thing is the area 52 military
compound up here it's the Nazi head
honchos installed the [ __ ]
Oberkommando down here below cavernous
vault full of all kinds of weird-ass
technology alien [ __ ] it's all down
there now I haven't seen it myself but
it's there well whatever it is it ain't
okay alright nobody knows for sure
exactly what kind of technology we're
dealing with but it's most likely space
alien base it ain't space alien site all
kind of stuff do you know Oh guys are
you still you some kind of expert on all
things extraterrestrial now look I've
been all you're a long [ __ ] time and I
know a move on their [ __ ] conspiracy
when I see one
no okay I'm not saying it's space aliens
right but it goes without saying
it's [ __ ] space aliens I got a new
Monsieur fire extinguisher okay cool it
I did not mean to rile you grace told me
that you know away into the Oberkommando
you get me in there I will use this Newt
to blow the top brass of the Nazi
leadership to smithereens yes yes of
course that sounds so good
I'm here to help papa dug these tunnels
to the underground train system that
connects all the top-secret military
bases this tunnel goes right to area 52
cargo train loading depot
all right now you should put that nuke
in this backpack keep your hands-free
for shooting off the notches down there
and other things now I'll keep in touch
on the radio help you out
hey stay frosty blast
superfish
I'm arming the warhead now they want
about an Arras well before the sting
gospel I have my guys city house down
the tornado I'll evacuate the whole town
the lipfird execute the Holland lasso
the wrong building by the Elvis done
deal
you